i'm the kryptonite to the cynical that's
great that's it
i'm gonna be a real
bad thing for a lot of people who love
to tear down and be cynical i'm the one
person they should stay away from
because i'm gonna [ __ ] execute
because i'm a [ __ ] executor and i've
been my whole life garyvee what's up my
friends thank you for uh thank you for
joining me man sincerely appreciate it
super excited to be here with you my man
thank you brother i gotta i gotta start
with the question that we get to be
friends we get to all the good stuff but
really quickly
the question that i got to get
off my chest and off my family's chest
is when are we buying the jets and how
are we going to make that happen as
quickly as possible so i can avoid
getting the every sunday text from my
dad about how bad this team is when do
we get there
only god knows my friend but boy oh boy
am i giving it a real college try i uh i
often clarify for people that
trying to buy the new york jets is my
real
[Music]
my real um
like happy zone right
that i'd love to buy the jets but if it
doesn't happen it'll be more than fine
i'll be more than fine but the great
enjoyment of my professional life has
been trying to
and i'm giving it a real at-bat from
where i started when i decided in fourth
grade to where i am right now gives me
real hope over the next 30 years that i
can pull it off dude i believe you and i
think that there's no one who's been
who's kept it real for that long through
a lot a lot of ups and downs mostly
downs that they want to make that that's
the goal that's the end goal but do you
think do you think that a regular fan or
regular people and i say regular people
it's all relative
but will ever own a football team i
think the nba has made strides to make
it part of like that aspirational goal
like own an nba team and you kind of see
regular folk getting into the mix do you
think a group of fans or a fan or a
regular person will ever own a football
team or you think that's kind of like
the old boys club it'll stay that way
forever didn't there's a way in
no and i don't think there's a way in
the nba or mlb or anything else either i
mean just think about the sheer amount
of wealth and just think about the sheer
amount of
units there are right how many we're
talking about you take all three of
those sports you've got a hundred teams
that means only a hundred people
out of right 330 million americans 8
billion people on earth like
it's a ridiculous thing i think the
thing to look out for for the
quote-unquote regular folk which i'm one
of and i understand that i'm starting to
build some wealth creation that puts me
in a different place but
you know i just bought a pickleball team
i own with the minnesota vikings
ownership group the wilfs a big chunk of
an esports
team that has a call of duty and rocket
league you know
regular quote-unquote folk could have
bought a football and a basketball team
in the 50s and 60s they still had to be
rich but it wasn't like what it is now
and so
i think you have to almost look for the
emerging sports
you know yeah i think that the seeing
the pickleball announcement and seeing
that you're involved in a space that is
still growing and you see that a lot in
tech especially where somebody finds
something where there's a it's a little
bit of a niche but it's got a really
engaged community and really engaged fan
base and that's kind of like a great
starting point to get people into sports
ownership i think that that's a that's
kind of a good segue i want to talk
obviously series two and i want to talk
about everything going on with v friends
and v con but starting with community
and building from the ground up i want
to talk
v friends and the impact of series one i
think that it's coming up on us one year
anniversary in may i think just by the
numbers because i think most people
outside of this space outside of web 3
they're going to look at success in the
nft space as you know money metric you
got half a billion dollars in total
transactions a top 20 nft all time by
volume uh around the 15th floor right
now which is around 50 thousand dollars
give or take 350 000 people in a discord
um one of the most active discords
you'll find anywhere just never-ending
amount of conversation and commentary
that's going on so you're a positive guy
everyone knows that you have a way of
seeing the future in this kind of really
bright way brighter than anybody else
potentially would did you expect when
you were starting to post those drawings
like a year ago a little more than a
year ago that you would get to this
point or did those numbers kind of
exceed expectations did you see it
getting to this point
exceeded expectations and i also think
that has to do with the frothy nature of
the space
you know there's a lot of stuff that's
going to go to zero that has 100 million
dollar valuations or market caps so i
think i my project got caught up with
the current of how much
the
hype and you know i view it as
my job is to be jeff bezos
to the best of my ability obviously he's
one of the best that has ever done it in
creating wealth from a company
but i don't see any reason why i
shouldn't aspire to be at that level
and
amazon was 120 bucks a share in 99 and
then it was six bucks a share in 2000
and then it's three thousand dollars a
share and that's the journey i'm on i
think the numbers are enormous right now
i think that in a 20-year window
it's a
you know my job is to make it a value
play
but do i think that the market is so
riddled with greed and things of that
nature i i do and i think that
corrections come along with that
do i equally believe i'm the guy i do
and that will i'll either be right and
i'll clip this in 30 years and be like
see
on the rally podcast with rob i told you
i was the guy or i'll clip it and say
let me tell you why i was wrong i wasn't
the guy here's the mistakes i made
that's kind of what i've signed up for
which is like
who gives a [ __ ] of how successful i am
financially there's been trillions of
people that have been financially
successful through the history of time
i think what's more interesting is which
humans came along that actually
genuinely deeply ingrained in their dna
were interested in everybody winning
alongside them that's kind of what i've
realized about myself and when i look
back at my life building a business for
my dad starting 50 50 partnership with
my brother helping so many of my friends
acquaintances random people
i get a high on other people winning two
and so
that's what i'm focused on and that's
why i love nfts like all these holders
of be friends one and two
will inherently
ride the tailwinds of what i do well
over the next 40 years yeah and i'll say
that you've done a really good job of
being very transparent about that i
think that you've talked about you know
the nft winter and what's going to
happen that there will be those ups and
downs i think your community in
particular has been understanding of
temporary pullbacks or situations where
it's not exactly what they expected but
they're looking at the long term i think
that's a a bit of the miss from a lot of
nft projects and communities right now
was looking for an immediate flip but
seeing something at year end do what
your project has done to this point is
super inspiring for a lot of people
doing new projects and your community is
so
behind that long-term goal which you've
always said i think uh you know to to
take it full circle before getting into
series two
the team you have around you and the
people that i've known through you over
the course of the last like four or five
years starting with like uh the first
conversation with with nick dio for
example we were in la and uh maybe two
weeks ago three weeks ago and he was out
there my girlfriend was with me she met
nick we hung out for a little bit the
next day she was like he's the nicest
person i've ever met their whole team is
so nice and i'm thinking about it in
terms of empathy you get the most out of
everyone around you and that's your
community the people that work with you
because because i give the most
well i'll give you that too and you said
it on instagram two days ago you're
talking about like empathy a lot of
people get big and they get money they
get a little bit arrogant and they
forget that like the people that helped
you build it are the ones that are the
most important what's how do you get the
most out of the group around you whether
it's the community of three hundred
thousand or so people like that
it's so simple rob like like
first of all thank you for sharing that
story just makes me so happy first of
all it's it's about giving nick
is the vp of my core relationships his
job for a living and i pay him well
is to bring value to everybody that i
tell him to or that he stumbles upon
based on knowing me the end
do you know how insane of a job that is
the craziest i told him that i said like
the p going to forge these channels and
staying positive all day doing it it's
something you do well but it exudes
itself from everyone around you too the
people around you believe it and they're
on that journey you know
well look nick's been with me for eight
eight nine years right it's not you know
i also don't hire randomly people come
into the vayner x ecosystem there's a
lot of strategy behind vaynermedia and
vaynerx that's not obvious which is
yeah it's a company and it yeah it's a
big ass company
and you know vaynerx is gonna do well
over 300 million dollars in revenue this
year so it's not a small company
but it's really my playing ground to
teach
to
form relationships the trust level i
have for alexandra raffington
lou
tyler nick dio andy
may she's insane i trust may with my
life
you know like and she's been only with
me for four years but i know when i know
and i build and
we build
that's the move i mean that and that
leads me to series two so you have this
this huge community you got this great
team behind you you have 15 new
characters uh a reasonable mint price i
will say which you can easily charge
more for um i got to put that out there
never investment advice but it is
something that you see a lot of really
crazy mint prices recently to see the
evolution of the project and where it's
gone where it's gotten to from both the
the art and the team perspective uh but
also in terms of conversation it's so
relevant i think a lot of people come to
me and they have a conversation about
nfts the first time they really heard
about nfts and utilities associated with
nfts has been v friends so now you have
series two where's this real evolution
it's a mix of kind of physical you have
v con coming up you have the digital
with the nft projects that go with it
how far do you think the physical
product and the experience play into
this iteration and then going forward
with what will potentially be series
three or the next iteration of v friends
how much of the physical world is going
to melt with that nft going forward
what's everything to me i think about
the real world
almost more than the digital world
you know like the uno collaboration the
zero you know obviously you're in
collecting i mean look at these zero
coil prices it's nuts it's nuts i mean
it's like literally with national
treasures and exquisite like well it's
like it's real stuff it's um
i think a lot about supply and demand
i've always been good at it from
baseball cards to wine
i've just always been good at it which
is really paying off dividends but i
think about amusement park i think about
uh rob i've had
an incredible amount of energy deployed
against amusement park
now amusement park might be 13 years
from now
um i think i mean i'm wearing like this
hoodie really matters like this
ambitious hoodie that i'm wearing that
wears it on the left yeah that has the
ambitious angel i know this is all audio
but i'm showing you i'm going to sleep
right like
candy
actual candy um cereal actual cereal
toys actual toys
um
you know
iphone games
tv shows
stamps
how how important is that nostalgia do
you think because i'm looking at series
two and the characters have evolved from
the original drawings and the doodles
that you had that were in series one to
where we are now it looks like it lends
itself to all these things like that 90s
era cartoon and the candy is that is
that all part of the thought process
when you're putting together new
characters 100
yeah in the 90s were the 90s were a very
specific moment and this feels like the
perfect 90s in 2022 you know what i mean
yeah it it and really because of my age
it has a real 70s 80s and 90s to a tier
point there's a lot of nickelodeon in it
you know dora the explorer
when i look at it sometimes like oh that
looks right then it's but then it's also
like really thought about from a care
bears smurfs
snorkels you know like
um and then and then like hannah barbera
tom and jerry like
it's definitely an impact the last 50
years of pop culture character
development
and then and then i think long term like
look i want to build
that disney vibe but i also want to
build on top of kif
palace
you know
off-white virgin may rest in peace like
these iconic people that have come along
in streetwear and fashion and at some
point black panther anime adult swim
so like at some point when i think about
series three four five six seven over
next 50 years
some of these characters are going to
age up you look at batman the way he was
drawn in the beginning
the way he was cartoon eyes
in the 90s he got grown up as [ __ ] yeah
yeah like that simpsons look too like
everything sort of changes over time and
it becomes more mature you know yeah
when batman's when bane broke batman's
back in comic form that's very different
than what we saw in the 60s and if
right
whether it was on comic book form or
what we saw with adam west so i think in
those terms you know i think about what
a logo
a lego superman movie superman looks
like
and i think about superman on feature
film and i think superman in a comic
book i think about superman in you know
the action figures from the 80s that i
collected superman in the 1970s migo
collectibles i'm a historian in pop
culture collectibles i really am and
it's going to end up being all those
hours of learning in the my teenage
years my 20s and all the garage sailing
i did it's just all culminating yeah i
mean so again i'm going to show you
something you know this is mainly audio
but like i go to random stores look at
this i just buy stickers like nah i did
the same thing dude
that's what you got to do it's just
we're in a general the same general age
category it's that nostalgia and bring
it back to life you know look at this
it's crazy
i believe it yeah what do you have do
you have a storage unit or something
where you're keeping all this stuff
right now yeah i assume you have so much
stuff where's the stuff
how storage also you know whatever the
[ __ ] i could figure out
you know what's great about it all for
me
the friends to the jets is gonna work
out for me because i'm authentically
both meaning
meaning i'll show you again because i'm
in show-and-tell mode again i know this
is audio but like
i'm actually a comic-con sports card
kind of like i'm into that [ __ ] right
what everybody's listening to the
podcast right now what i'm showing
you know rob is a star wars original
package greedo great killer
you know like this is like really like
i'm about that life right like i've been
doing it the whole time thank god i got
the receipts on the internet like when
when i talk about pop culture stuff we
can pull up all the receipts from trash
talk where i'm like talking about
hanna-barbera this or pokemon nah
absolutely no question and that's
something that i think we think about
like at rally we're always thinking
about it in terms of like a mix of the
the stuff that was relevant in the past
what's relevant right now but what will
be relevant in the future and it's like
that future nostalgia you have somebody
now who's in between 30 and 50 years old
there's a very specific 70s 80s and 90s
vibe that goes with it but it all comes
back around so to see things that are
digital that have that digital
sort of wallet that it's associated with
but it's got the physical feel of
something from a different era that hits
on all these different things that it
becomes like my wallet in the future
will not be like my apartment and the
extra room that i have that's full of
collectibles it might be full of the
same thing digitally but thinking about
in terms of a franchise the way you're
thinking about it i think it could be
omni channel it could be anything
to me it's both right like i mean why
did i grade my drawings that we're doing
together yeah i mean that's and that
that lends itself to the real
conversations i'm thinking about in
terms of you said it logan paul actually
played a clip like
two weeks ago an old clip of you was
from 2010 saying you know what i'm
really passionate about is virtual
currency and that's before
anybody even understood what you were
talking about but it's all come full
circle and that now you have the
physical you have the digital you have
digital currency that can be paid for
either one of those you have it in a
digital wallet in a physical wallet it's
all coming to merge right now so like a
few months back and this goes to the to
the series one original drawing on rally
but a few months back um there was this
auction for the five of the original
drawings at christie's and that's one of
the premier auction houses that's
responsible for some of the biggest
sales of the last decade there's only
two right
that's it and it's the five original
garyvee drawings they go for over 1.3
million dollars so
now you have just to cut through a
couple numbers quick and get your
reaction you have
a basic andy warhol sketch right now
around 20 000 give or take um a really
good example of a salvador dali might be
might be 30 it could be if it could
really be authenticated um you can get a
great picasso right now like a good a
really good sketch that led to a
painting for like a hundred thousand
garyvee drawing around 275 thousand
dollars did art is polarizing right is
this super subjective everyone's opinion
is correct
do you consider this art do you consider
yourself an artist knowing the price of
your art now commands in the open market
do you consider yourself an artist
yeah but only because i
i
like
in 40 years like when people look at the
sketches they're like [ __ ] this but i'm
like yo did you see the sketch of mickey
mouse like it wasn't so or bart simpson
like or tom and jen like they're not so
complex at first and then
i think my art is that i can paint
pictures i'm a storyteller i do it as
garyvee
and i've been able to storytell
remarkably i i had a huge impact in a in
a very narrow way in the wine business
through my storytelling reviewing wine
it changed
the temperature of it being snooty to
being a little bit more blue-collar
i think
as far as the last 15 years of
influencers and personalities on the
internet um
i'm in the mix i'm one of the people
that came out of it you know it's not
like i'm on tv or anything else like i
built my whole world there
and
and i'm really proud of that
and now as the architect of making
patient panda an accountable aunt and
you know sharing squirrel and all this
stuff matter
teaching people good virtues through
characters
i will do that
in a very successful way i know for fact
when i go into the ground hopefully in
55 years
like
you know
that people will say
gary vaynerchuk the creator of the
friends i actually believe that
even if i buy even if i buy the jets on
the back of building v friends my
intuition says
first line is creator v friends because
i think v friends
is going to be my scaled
masterpiece
you know i think building garyvee
has been profoundly satisfying for gary
vaynerchuk because i'm the architect of
the strategy not even being the front
man of it but i only scale so much i
have a certain style that doesn't click
for everyone i'm a 46 year old white
male that doesn't click for everyone
there's a million things that don't
click my per like i'm competitive like i
get it like for 30 of the world it's
[ __ ] the best for 20 of the world
it's solid for 10 percent of the world
it's okay and for 40 of the world it's
not like i get all those dynamics
there's 8 billion people but
v friends can be 100 penetration
and that's my and that's my focus
and
so let me ask you this and you've
answered this before but it's a question
and i asked the art question it was very
loaded because in my mind you just
described art it's emotion it's
polarizing it gets people to sort of pay
attention and build communities it's
really what the output itself is a is a
thing it's a tangible thing we can lean
on but at the same time the community
built around it is what brings ideas to
life
so to me it is art and when i think
about you know the polarization around
it to me that's a good thing but when
you're in a situation and i know you've
been asked this before
if someone looks at you and sees your
art and sees this piece that we're doing
our rally or sees you on tv with a
statement about the nft space and they
go he's full of [ __ ] what do you what is
your response does it even affect you at
this point or is that something you just
know comes with the territory
i'm empathetic
you know when you rattle off all those
names that first of all i assume and i'm
not educated there's a lot of sketches
out there of those characters this has a
specific thing with a small group of
people that have been following me for
20 years who do believe i'm going to
build disney and either they're going to
be right or wrong so that's why i think
it commanded that kind of price
my intuition
on that is excuse me my reaction to that
is compassion
i understand why people think that rob
makes sense to me
i have no interest in convincing people
that i it's right
i can only focus on executing to make it
right
that's a killer answer i gotta give you
that one because i mean there's a lot of
people who don't want someone to be
right they don't want someone who has a
following to sort of be to be right they
want to say oh you see it didn't work
out you know like that's the thing it's
prevalent i'm on the kryptonite to the
cynical that's great that's it
i'm gonna be a real
bad thing for a lot of people who love
to tear down and be cynical i'm the one
person they should stay away from
because i'm gonna [ __ ] execute
because i'm a [ __ ] executor and i've
been my whole life
long before there was [ __ ] gary vee i
was a child and built a huge business
for my dad with no money
right like
nobody gives a [ __ ] on madison avenue
that i'm gary vee i walked into that
industry as a liquor store
child and [ __ ] built the biggest
independent agency in the world like
like i wasn't an investor and i walked
into the game investing in facebook
twitter and tumblr and hitting like i'm
the wrong dude to be cynical about if
you do not want to be wrong amongst your
friends
about being cynical because so many
people are not good at executing and
will fail and are full of [ __ ] you need
to focus on them because if you come
down my path and be like this is
[ __ ] he's going to lose i've done 20
years of proving you wrong and for
everybody who's listening i will
continue to do that in your [ __ ] face
right in your [ __ ] mouth for the rest
of my life
and trying to trying to trying to time
uh a top on anybody is always a problem
with you in particular it's going to be
very problematic i could see the same
thing happening no question so on that
note i just i just
am too good at this i believe it i'm too
good of a businessman i have to i've too
good of intent the mcdo story like i've
got this this is what i do this like
when i remember i mean i wish
we had social media the way we have this
when lebron came out i was so bullish
lebron
bought a shitload of his cards it was
the first time i came back into the game
since 94. that's documented by the way
documented that's not that's not that's
not
[ __ ]
you're seeing 2018 where again i doubled
down on 2004. lebron already did it by
then 2017. oh four oh three lebron i
guessed i had a feeling i also loved
dwyane wade because i loved him in in
the ncaa tournament but that was more
guessing lebron i was like i think this
is it and he played his first game
again i think against the clippers and
dropped like 22 or 18 i was like this is
it
new
took me out of retirement because i
retired in 93 94 from cards first time i
bought in 10 years missed that whole
10-year window the mcguire's all that
[ __ ]
and
all of my friends who said he was going
to suck
i wish they were on the record
like people just wanted to say he was
going to suck because everyone said he
was chosen
they were right about jabari parker rob
they were right about jabari parker but
lebron was the wrong guy but you know
how it is too it's like for every one
one thing that somebody gets right
there's ten they got wrong the problem
or the other way around all the way
around exactly that's what's gonna say
the other way around what happens it's
tough i i love when people say garyvee
you know when when i nail something
they'll be like yeah okay a clock gets
lucky twice i'm like yo 15 years of
content on the internet every day pull
the clips it's true it's all documented
[ __ ]
so i gotta i gotta say that that so now
we're at a point that a lot of this is
combination i'm thinking about vcon now
and it's a this is a stadium event so
i'm thinking about this as like series
one leading into series two but also in
a time where like big in-person events
are just starting to come back i see
this as like a web 2.5 play what should
what should we expect and what should
holders expect of v friends that have
tickets should they expect out of v con
that they're not going to get elsewhere
right now in the in person experience
well i mean this is
i mean what i haven't even announced
some of the names yet like
i mean this is way too like here's my
answer vcon 2023
is going to be like
incredibly sought after because the post
mortem of 2022 is gonna get everyone i
mean it's the culmination of the nft
culture everyone's gonna be there
it's gonna be fantastic we're gonna care
i've got back to my inner circle
literally yesterday with andy the
president
be friends like hey i gotta give some of
my nft tickets
to like 15 of our inner circle people at
vayner wine library i just need my
family there because anything that goes
wrong i need to be able to take texts
and be like regav go take care of this
like i need my homies like we have
incredible volunteers incredible
infrastructure incredible people have
been friends but i was like andy let's
get 15 of the family members there
because i know i can rely on them
because if rob's having a bad like
something broke or
anybody that's there is not having a
perfect time i want to be able to fix it
and i need to have my infrastructure
there so i think it's going to be
phenomenal you can't look the real world
really matters i nobody's more bullish
on the digital world than me i've made
my whole career on it but it's an and
game not an or game
that's a great way to put it that's a
good way to put it and it's all like
we're reopening our new museum in soho
and we're thinking about like what in
person
events are going to be and i think it's
more of what vcon is where it's curated
in a way that it's not four million
people begging for attention or trying
to jump on a stage it's an event that
it's it's a long ways in the making
you're part of it early you get to be
part of it now and it's also like
incredible experience and and memory
that comes from it that you can take
elsewhere and say to your point the 2023
version what do we do right what do we
do wrong how do we make this even bigger
next year to do it in a smaller group to
start and really well curated as a way
to make that stuff happen we think the
same way here
i love that listen you know i think with
the innovation that you you all have
brought to the game like
it's so cool right like
wall street didn't exist at one point
and either you owned a business
completely or you didn't and now
i own a piece of netflix and tesla and
it's really neat and like i'm really
excited about this project i picked the
sharing squirrel because it's sharing
yeah you know and i think it's gonna be
really cool i have real big ideas for
that character long term too so i think
long term the people with the huddle
hands are going to really work out but
it's i'm really excited about i really
feel like people are going to be able to
at a very low cost be really in the game
when the floor of one of my series one
nfts is 50 000 when the when the supply
and demand for the 1 000
series 2 like i'm very concerned because
i don't like bubble behavior how
expensive they're going to be 24 hours
later when somebody's gonna be able to
own the holy grail which is the original
art at the fraction price that you guys
are offering like
it's [ __ ] cool like i like doing
things that i would do as a consumer on
the other side which is why this was a
yes no i appreciate that and that's we
always think about i think the same way
you do too it's the community is what
builds this platform and what's done
what rally's done well i think over time
is making sure that you have that access
but also that we're here for the long
term so we're always looking for assets
regardless of what it is where there's
like that long-term behavior and not
that flipped behavior that goes with it
so this was a natural conversation i
appreciate you doing it with us for sure
i got to end with i got to end with one
question
so
over the last you know three or four
months you've you've been on tv a couple
times you've had a lot of really great
things to say and commentary on the
space what does it feel like to get
asked a gotcha question on tv and then
have the exact right answer queued up to
just deliver absolute smoke to a
journalist on live tv
and then i also want to know was that a
premeditated murder or was that in
self-defense i'm not 100 sure after it
became the meme i was reviewing it i'm
always self defense i never come in with
negative intent i'm a counter puncher
even though
i look like somebody who would be the
aggressor based on my energy
yet there's nothing better than to stay
very narrow and talk about what you know
i'm very proud that i do that i stay
very narrow in my [ __ ]
i talk about perspective and just like
how a human has control of seeing the
world the way
that they can if they understand kind of
the human eq elements of being a human i
stick to business i stick to pop culture
and sports
i stick to wine and marketing
and i stick to you know web 3 nft
kind of strategy
and that's it and so when i go and do an
interview like that and out of nowhere
you're caught off guard because now
you're like oh [ __ ] this is the tone the
journalist wants to take it
there's just no better feeling than when
you are
about your life i'm not reading off of a
you know off of a teleprompter i'm not
living off of a deck that my team made
for me i lived this [ __ ] 24 7. i know it
cold
uh and so that was a lot of fun and
obviously when your face becomes a meme
for a moment uh it's pretty cool
i think i got to give you credit dude
that's like you don't have to study it
when you're a student of the game and it
just comes natural so i think that's
something that you've always sort of had
that authenticity comes through for sure
gary i appreciate it man thank you so
much looking forward to the the rally v
friend offering on uh on our platform
and looking forward to v con in series
two thanks so much
cheers
thanks dude i'm gonna stop this and